[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une critique qui revient souvent
sur vous et votre musique on dit que
vous êtes une Vendée et depuis quand
c'est les autres qui m'imposent qui je
dois être
la musique n'a pas de frontière je
chante ce que je veux je décide qui je
veux être et je veux toucher un public
aussi large que possible
[Musique]
il n'y en a pas deux comme toi tu as une
voix unique
Whitney tu es ma petite princesse
on s'occupe de développer ta carrière
tout ce que tu as à faire c'est chanter
mon argent
[Musique]
je te faisais confiance tu étais censé
me protéger
[Musique]
vous deux vous passez beaucoup de temps
ensemble sa nuit à l'image de la marque
depuis quand ta fille est devenue une
marque j'ai loupé un épisode
te prends pas la tête avec ça tu es où
[Musique]
ça t'a fait quoi tout ces témoignages
d'amour de ces millions de gens
[Musique]
j'ai jamais rien ressenti d'aussi fort